Speaker 1: . Now it is time for Joe Biden
to get something else done.
Now, if you look at Joe Biden's first 100
day accomplishments, they are significant.
They aren't all exactly the accomplishments
that the progressive left would want.
There are other things we would like for him
to have promised and be working on and ideally
have done.
But it can't be denied that it was an extremely
productive first 100 days.
I believe it is now time to move ahead without
Republicans because they simply are not willing
to participate, probably in the infrastructure
bill.
And Senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont is now
urging Democrats pushed through the infrastructure
package without any Republican support.
Just do it.
Bernie was interviewed by ACOSS.
This aired last night, I believe, and he disagreed
with the perspective of some Democratic strategists,
which is that Republicans must be part of
the deal that Democrats strike if Democrats
are going to pass the sweeping infrastructure
package.
Bernie said, quote, In general, I don't agree
with that.
The bottom line is the American people want
results.
And Bernie said that voters, when it came
to the one point nine dollars billion stimulus,
nobody.
I mean, listen, you can find some people,
right?
If you go to like the villages in Florida
and we will have video from that over the
weekend, you can probably find some people
who say, I was mad at the cash I got.
From Biden, because no, no Republicans voted
for it, you can find it to a country of three
hundred and thirty one million, but big picture,
you don't have a wave of opposition to the
fact that people got money in March or whenever
it was passed because no Republican supported
that.
And maybe even some Republicans are going
to suffer the electoral consequences of that
come 2022.
And Bernie is saying essentially the same
thing, which is what we've been saying, what
many have been saying.
The infrastructure bill is popular.
The infrastructure bill is popular with almost
all Democrats and the majority of independents
and many Republicans.
If Republicans really want to dig their heels
in or stick their head in the sand or whatever
metaphor or analogy you want to use and take
the political risk of all voting against something
that Americans widely support, want and believe
that we need and that will be economically
stimulative.
The infrastructure plan let Republicans all
vote against it.
Mitch McConnell has already said Democrats
will have zero votes on this infrastructure
package as written.
We know there's not going to be zero Republican
support.
Why negotiate into something that will end
up being a garbage bill when even if you do
that, you may get and are likely to get zero
Republican votes?
So it's really a simple question.
Is Joe Biden committed to doing infrastructure
in twenty twenty one?
It's a really simple decision tree.
If no, then there's then there's 10 options.
Negotiate in bad with bad faith.
Republicans water the bill down, postpone
it till 2022.
Right.
I mean, if the answer is no, we're not committed
to getting it passed this year.
The world is your oyster.
Go do whatever the hell you want.
If the answer is yes, we're committed to passing
it this year, then you just have to pass it
without Republican support.
As much as there is some risk to Democrats
passing another major bill with no Republican
support, I believe the risk is greater for
Republicans when the bills are popular, when
the American people don't really care whether
if they think the things should be done.
Most of the American people are not doing
this inside the Beltway stuff of, oh, I don't
know.
I mean, like if if Mitch McConnell had voted
for it, then I'd feel much better about accepting
my fourteen hundred dollars.
That basically doesn't exist other than anecdotally.
So I think the risk is greater for the Republicans.
Now, there is a practical question.
It is not totally clear whether Democratic
Senators Joe Manchin and Kirsten Sinema want
the infrastructure bill passed as written.
Manchin has already played coy with this idea
of bipartisanship with bad faith.
Actors who have no interest in what you're
doing is also a question mark.
So without a doubt, Bernie's plan only works
if you have every Democratic senator on board.
But there is no question that it's time to
do it and it must be done without Republican
support because you're not going to get Republican
support.
Mitch McConnell has said it.
If Mitch McConnell wants to obstruct, let
him do it, but get things done.
I would rather if I were Joe Biden, I would
rather potentially suffer the consequences
for doing things without Republicans than
suffer the consequences for not getting a
damn thing done.
I think Joe Biden prefers the former as well.
And we're going to we're going to see very
soon if they decide to go ahead with this
Monday, Memorial Day.
By the way, we are going to do our first one
day membership special in a very long time.
I think it was February, the last time we
did this, maybe early March.
We are going to have a one day membership
special.
It's going to be an ungodly immoral discount.
So if you've been thinking about grabbing
a membership, getting the extra bonus show
every day, all of these things just get on
my newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom.
And then on Monday, Memorial Day, you will
get an email telling you how to sign up.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is made
possible by members, viewers and listeners
who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom, we have
had some really good bonus shows lately.
We're looking at even giving some of them
awards because they've been so good